bester höhle der löwen jura und
bestseller autor carsten maschmeyer sein
neues werk die startup gängen ich habe
sie noch mal mitgebracht unser größtes
abenteuer von der idee zum erfolg ist
heute erschienen und hat direkt platz 1
der amazon charts ehrung herzlichen
glückwunsch herr maschmeyer schön dass
sie da sind neben im bild politik chef
jan schäfer niemand erklärt politik so
wie er auch ich lerne jeden haben wieder
einiges wenn er dabei ist und sie werden
heute abend einiges über die ökologen
der grünen lernen an meiner seite der
konsequenteste kolumnist deutschland
fahrradmarken stein bis februar 2022
schrieb jede sonntags ausgabe des
tagesspiegels eine kolumne nach einer
löschung seines artikels durch die
chefredaktion verließ mackenstein die
zeitpunkt freue mich sehr dass er heute
über die bedrohung der meinungsfreiheit
sprechen wird last but not least unser
stammgast roger köppel niemand wird auf
youtube so sehr sehnt wie er und niemand
liebt lebendige debatten so sehr wie er
damit herzlich willkommen falls ihr es
alle erst einmal eingeschaltet haben
jeder für uns dann ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt schockiert berührt freut
oder was ja einfach mal mit anderen
menschen teilen möchte und jetzt habe
ich auch genug geredet und wir machen
direkt weiter mit harry tisch seien ja
finnland es gibt bei uns im westen der
westlichen welt zwei neue bedrohungen
der meinungsfreiheit und damit der
demokratie finde ich die oft
unterschätzt werden die eine nenne ich
die identität ideologie dann werde jetzt
viel sagen hey was ist das denn es ist
ganz einfach zu erklären
man teilt die menschheit in zwei hälften
auf der einen seite
sind die guten und auf der anderen seite
sind die bösen die guten sind die
diskriminiert werden also wegen ihres
geschlechtes wegen der hautfarbe
wegen ihrer sexualität und so weiter die
bösen sind die diskriminieren also wenn
er rausgeht homosexuelle usw der clou
bei dieser sache ist dass man nichts tun
muss und zu diskriminieren also man muss
nicht wirklich jemanden diskriminiert
haben man ist einfach wahr dieser
eigenschaft also zum beispiel weiß zu
sein ist man ein diskriminierender oder
einlass ist und umgekehrt ist es genauso
sie können ein millionär in beverly
hills sein und sich und diskriminiert
sein weil sie eben schwachsinn als
das ist eine irgendwie ihre ideologie
finde ich aber sie hat sehr viele
anhänger gefunden in grünen bei den
linken und hat auch bei der spd
und
sie hat auch in den vielen medienhäusern
stabile mehrheiten zwischen erreicht ich
halte sie deswegen für gefährlich weil
sie absolut intolerant ist und wenn man
der auffassung ist wir sind die guten
die anderen sind die bösen ist das ja
auch irgendwie konsequent in tolerant zu
sein
die ja und eine sache ist noch wichtig
die diese ideologie hat starke
ähnlichkeit mit zwei anderen totalitären
ideologien nämlich einerseits den
nationalismus und erfolg ist das beste
die anderen taugen nichts und auf der
anderen seite mit dem kommunismus und
dem marxismus
kapitalisten böse arbeiterklasse gut das
ist also ein sehr schlichtes weltbild
dass man also recyceln kann auf diese
art und weise die zweite wie ich finde
gefährliche haltung die es immer
häufiger gibt heißt
meine meinung ist
wissenschaft das ist auch irgendwie irre
und das gab es auch schon im axis musste
hat sich auf seine wissenschaft gehalten
und es gibt die wissenschaft ja auch
eigentlich gar nicht die wissenschaft
ändert ihrer meinung ständig die
wissenschaft vor 30 jahren ist nicht
mehr viel wert also ein letztes beispiel
zu dieser sache wenn karl lauterbach zum
beispiel sagt der virologe
dessen meinung ich gerne höre das ist
die stimme der wissenschaft posten heißt
da und der virologe dessen meinung ich
mich super an höhere steuer heißt der
ist zweiter klasse zweitklassig auf den
müssen wir nicht zu hören also das ist
auch eine art und weise freie debatten
zu verhindern und einzuschränken indem
man bedeutet ist
ja in der hornhaut martenstein trifft
hier natürlich den punkt eines wirklich
beunruhigen phänomens ich habe mir
überlegt dass das glücklicherweise auf
der anderen seite des ozeans vor allem
bei den vereinigten staaten stattfindet
oder den unis da wird derzeit fast schon
das geht dann schon in den klinischen
wahnsinn hinein was dort zum teil
geleert wird auch das breitet sich hier
auch aus es ist kein neues phänomen
es ist eigentlich das klassische führer
wie dem gesagt das klassische
gutmenschentum und das was das
eigentlich ist niemand ist dagegen gute
menschen niemand ist gegen das gute aber
der gutmensch der redet nur vom guten
meint aber sich selbst und das ist jedem
perfide technik man benutzt
toleranz scheinbare wachsamkeit
empfindsamkeit um sich damit auf ein
moralisches podest zu stellen und uns
normalsterblichen ein schlechtes
gewissen einzel jahren ich sage immer
oder ich spüre dann immer wenn das
eintritt was sie gesagt haben dass ich
vom inquisitoren gesichtern umzingelt
binnen von diesen schießscharten augen
die mit lauernder einfalt versuchen wir
die worte so im mund umzudrehen fake
news dass man mich irgendwie auf dem
grillrost der politischen korrektheit
spedieren kann wir sind ja vier weiße
männer hier da heißt das heißt wir
müssen schon jetzt auch in der logik
extrem aufpassen was wir sagen ist fast
schon eine das kriminelle sendung die
wir dann ja hier schreiben ja aber war
ja aber vielleicht dürfen und zu
gewissen themen war ja frau gar nicht
äußern aber scherz beiseite ich glaube
das was roger köppel sagt geht auch in
der richtige richtung ich glaube aber
trotzdem dass es noch eine entwicklung
zusätzlich gegeben hat also das ist
nicht immer schon so war sondern dass
wir ja auch sehen selbst befreit ist
future wird gecancelt wenn man plötzlich
als weißer oder als weiße die falsche
falsche frisur trägt also da kommt mir
glaube schon in bereiche die ganz neu
sind cancelled culture ist ja an sich
ein ausdruck von angst also sie haben
das glaube ich ganz gut auch beschrieben
der nationalismus der kommunismus sind
ja eigentlich angst ideologien man weiß
man ist schwach und man versucht es dann
über gewisse aussagen und gewisse andere
merkmale sich stark zu fühlen also da
ist vieles was glaube ich da
zusammenkommen ein punkt den ich machen
möchte ist und ich glaube diese kerschl
tänzelte hat sich schon in die politik
bei uns gezogen gibt beispielsweise ein
bundeskanzler der beim thema und sie
haben gerade angesprochen auch beim
thema corona doch sehr auf die
wissenschaft gehört hat aber wenn es
beispielsweise um ökonom geht da hat er
gerade vor kurzem bei anne will gesagt
nein also dass wir alles quatsch was da
berechnet wurde er hat auch als der
wissenschaftliche beirat vor ein paar
monaten der wissenschaftliche beirat des
wirtschaftsministers etwas zum thema
rente erreichen hat gesagt hat das sieht
alles ziemlich düster aus da hat er den
vorgeworfen diesen ökonom dass sie
falsch gerechnet hätten das machen
damals der finanzminister scholz einfach
so aus der menge das hat auch was mit
cancelled aber als brillenträger jan
schäfer sind wir auf der sicheren seite
war wie gehören auch zu einer
opfergruppe wir sind die opfergruppe der
kunst haben wir haben ihren war habe ich
hier die mehrheit also los nehmen wir
noch mal die wissenschaftler was ich
reklamiere ist dass man die nicht in
einen raum gesperrt und die mit namen
mit einer konsolidierten meinung
rauskommt also ja es mag extreme
ansichten gehen der eine forscht er so
und der andere hat den blickwinkel aber
ich würde mehrere anhören irgendwie die
mehrheit oder das konsolidierte votum
nehmen und den privilegierten das kennen
wir in der start up welt gar nicht
migrationshintergrund diverse teams
älter jünger weiblich männlich
flüchtlingskinder dabei das haben wir
nicht da da regiert pragmatismus in der
start up szene gibt es das nicht das
finde ich einen ganz wesentlichen punkt
den sie jetzt gebracht haben das ist
nämlich die außerkraftsetzung des
leistungsprinzips wenn man die
menschheit nur noch auf teilt nach
biologischen herkunfts kriterien des
biologismus eine ganz üble geschichte
und das gute an der marktwirtschaft ist
ja dass das leistungsprinzip geht das
heißt unabhängig woher ich komme welche
religion welche hautfarbe welche
haarfarbe habe ich kann ich mich
aufgrund der leistung die ich in den
augen anderer erbringe in einem völlig
neuen gesellschaftlichen status bringen
und das mit gerückt abgewickelt
durchlese kenzo und life city und was
ist das da noch diese
minderheitenpolitik auffällig ist
natürlich dass man
die verhältnisse einfach umdreht also
bei den rassisten klassischer werbung
ist natürlich hautfarbe und herkunft so
das ist das gewesen was man den leuten
zum fast war was der rassistischen
anderen zum vorwurf macht und nun dreht
man es um und man
macht den weißen ihrer hautfarbe und
ihre herkunft also fortschritt kann ich
nicht erkennen nur dass die rollen neu
besetzt werden aber man kann vielleicht
sogar sagen dass es sich darum eine
konstante der geschichte handelt denn
die haltung wir sind die guten die
anderen sind die bösen die hat es sehr
wahrscheinlich auch in der steinzeit
schon gegeben also wir kreisender um die
steinzeit und müssen erkennen dass
meinungsfreiheit und demokratie ja alles
andere als der normalfall der geschichte
ist das ist eine winzig kleine
historische zone in einer hand voll
ländern die wirklich freien
meinungsaustausch kennen den
demokratische verhältnisse herrschen das
ist immer betont dass es immer ein
minderheiten phänomen gewesen und
deswegen muss man halt ständig darum
kämpfen dass es so bleibt und jetzt ist
die große frage wird ein schlimmer mit
den jahren mit der zunehmenden nutzung
beispielsweise von social media wo man
sich in echo kammern nur noch anfällt
also eigentlich das ja so aussuchen kann
dass man nur noch mit lehm bestärkt wird
was man auch selbst hören möchte
ansonsten blockiert man einfach den
einen oder anderen nutzer ich glaube da
gibt es eine entwicklung dass er und das
ist anders als jetzt von der
startup-szene sich die menschen dann
genau diese echo kammer suchen kleider
in freundeskreisen kann man das auch
machen aber da kann man nicht einfach
sagen jetzt roger köppel sind sie
einfach mal leise aber ich kann sie
abstellen wenn ich
nicht schon längst damit angefangen nur
noch meine eigenen artikel zu lesen dass
mir meine eigene echo
kommt gut erhole mich da immer wieder
reißt das feld also manchmal muss man
sich vielleicht auch vor diesen anonymen
heckenschützen schützen ich vergleiche
das immer früher waren das an der
autobahn raste die die klo wende eine
obszöne sprüche waren
und irgendwelche gepflegten
telefonnummern und alles mögliche in der
anonymität dann die anderen über
leidigen oder zu diskreditieren oder
runter zu putzen das so leicht also da
meine ich dass die kommentare generell
immer mit einem identitätsnachweis gar
nicht dass man die adresse von der
person haben möchte aber dass dieses
anonyme beschmutzen nicht geben in
redaktion ich möchte keine namen nennen
aus rücksichtnahme habe ich manchmal
leute getroffen junge menschen die von
der universität kamen und in diesem
beruf gingen die waren echt
überrascht und geschockt dass es
menschen gibt die andere auffassungen
haben als sie das hatten sie also
erkennbar
nicht oder selten erlebt ja nicht in der
familie nicht nicht an der uni nicht in
ihrer peergroup ja wie man so sagt und
wenn sie dann jemandem gegenüber stehen
der sagt nur ich sehe das völlig aber in
einer isolierung browser ja und das ist
gute ihnen dann richtig weh das ist ganz
traurig und wissen nicht was sie tun
sollen
beim thema rollenbilder auf jeden fall
ein wenig und gehen weiter zurück köpfe
der war ein vorfall berichtet bei den
oscars den sie vielleicht sogar auch
schon bereit haben ja also der harald
martenstein hat vor natürlich wieder
visionär vorweg nehmen was ich da sagen
wollte das stichwort gesetzt nämlich das
stichwort steinzeit meine damen und
herren wir bewegen uns jetzt zurück in
die steinzeit des faust rechts und der
toxischen männlichkeit ich hätte nie
gedacht dass ich diesen begriff einmal
in den mund nehme ohne rot zu werden
oder dass mir die zunge abfahrt aber was
wir da gesehen haben toxische
männlichkeit bei den oscar find ich sage
das als jemand der ein ganz großer fan
ist von will smith ich habe gejubelt bei
idea for independence day also zusammen
mit jeff goldblum diesen todesmutigen
piloten spielte der die welt von der
außerirdischen bedrohung befreite und
was macht diese will smith gestern
gustav ein sie haben sicher davon gehört
oder vorgestern ich habe da die zeit
über sich verloren chris rock der
moderator der ganzen feierlichkeiten hat
einen witz gemacht der die frau von will
smith betroffen und es ist ein
grenzwertiger witz und ich kann das auch
verstehen dass sie nicht amüsiert war
wie es mit allerdings hat gelacht dann
aber plötzlich geht dies will smith
ansatzlos auf die bühne und schmiert
diesen chris rock also vor eine runter
eine breitseite
und das ist für mich als ehemaliger land
ok spielern linkes mittelfeld mit grünen
leibchen des luzerner sc eine klare in
go area das ist ein grobes foul eine art
blutgrätsche eine mediale blutgrätsche
und da muss man den spieler im
wettbewerb sofort
disqualifizieren und man hätte ihm
diesen oscar den er dann noch gewonnen
hat den müsste man ihm jetzt entziehen
dem will smith das geht einfach nicht
das ist das falsche vorbild und noch ein
weiterer punkt kommt dazu wir haben in
den letzten jahren dieses hollywood also
einen scheinheiligen tempo der
selbsternannten pseudo moral ein
bisschen im stich
von dem was er hauptmarkt stein erzählt
da gesehen die haben sich auf jedes
podest gestellt die haben den früheren
amerikanischen präsidenten trump für
jede deplatzierte twitter-meldung also
wirklich durch den fleischwolf gedreht
aber jetzt wenn einer der ihren dem dass
ich mir den kopf gestiegen ist dem
andern eine runter haut dann ist das
eine art dann läuft der show must go on
das finde ich nicht gut man müsste will
smith den oscar wegnehmen das ist nicht
die art und weise will man hier
auftreten sollte herr maschmeyer sollte
man ihm den oscar wegnehmen ich bin der
meinung nein der oscar ist eine ganz
klare auszeichnung für eine tätigkeit
für einen film da der eine hervorragende
hauptrolle gespielt es ist jetzt kein
preis fürs lebenswerk es ist keine
straße nach ihm benannt worden die
academy berät ja noch ob sie ihn
zukünftig ausschließen wollen wenn die
live entschieden hätten wäre die oscars
bekommen das wird ja vorher gewählt also
die der umschlag ist ja verschlossen das
musste ja nun wir sind glaube ich drei
leute vorher wer welche namen in welchem
umschlag stehen das halte ich nicht für
gerechtfertigt ich finde die reaktion
der körperlichen gewalt nicht gut gerade
in der heutigen zeit aber
ich kann etwas verstehen dass man auf
brauchst ich kann auch kritik ab
beleidigungen ab juni ab aber wenn es um
meine kinder geht oder meine frau und in
dem fall ist ja die frau von will smith
erkrankt und hat haarausfall und darüber
war dieser witz also dass er seine frau
verteidigt für mich vom grundsatz gut
aber das ganze ohne körperliche gewalt
wer geschickter und sogar nachhaltiger
völlig einverstanden wenn es denn so
eine auch böse gemeinte beleidigung
gewesen wäre aber diese chris rock ist
ja nicht ein böser
gemacht hatte sagte ich begrüße alle
anwesenden will smith djg jej und damit
spielt der run auf die den haarausfall
das ist der viel mit demi moore wo sie
eine marien chor kennerin gespielt doch
mit diesen hat sich also lustig gemacht
über das und ich glaube aber ich weiß es
nicht ich glaube dass chris rock hier
das nicht mit dieser bösartigkeit
gemeint hat das passt nicht zu seinem
charakter und ich glaube dass man das
problem hätte lösen können auch mit
einem verbalen spruch da hätte sich
nämlich entschuldigt und dass man hier
gleich raus geht wenn er ist das
wirklich aus gekostet hätte und das in
einer art und weise getan im april smith
und da kommt sie noch dazu hat ja am
anfang noch mitgelacht also
möglicherweise hatte gar nicht gemerkt
wie sie dass die frau verletzt hat darum
war das eine akte ein akt von nachholen
der ritterlichkeit in anführungszeichen
daneben im stall sei ja manchmal bei
sportlern fußballspieler im eishockey
böse fouls wo die hinterher sagen ich
war so im rausch ich möchte noch etwas
zu seiner verteidigung sagen oder alle
die dort sind nominiert sind ich ahne
wie viel liter blut durch den körper
fließt bekomme ich jetzt meinen ersten
oscar oder nicht da ist ein adrenalin
druck im normalen leben hätte mit
gelacht und gesagt pass auf wollte sie
doch jetzt bei meiner frau entschuldigen
das ist eine sonne
bei unserer beherrschen um ein detail
aus meinem familienalltag zu verraten
meine frau war begeistert von will
smiths ich auch und hat gesagt dass sie
sich von mir wenn sie mal öffentlich
beleidigt wird die gleiche reaktion
wünscht ist also die stimme der
toxischen weiblichkeit dazu will ich
würde das nie waren baroni
würde ich bringe ich bin körperlich also
was scheint also bei weitem nicht so fit
wie war's also ich kann das nicht machen
aber ich muss roger köppel in einem
punkt wirklich beipflichten wenn das
jemand aus in einem anderen lager und
einem anderen kontext gemacht hätte
irgend so ein reaktionärer republikaner
er würde wahrscheinlich bis zum ende
seines lebens keine sonne mehr sehen
das ist ja das ist er wer das ist halt
der liebe will smith und wer weiß
gewesen wäre wäre das ja noch am es
einer werden gute er ist einer von den
guten und da darf er das machen es ist
natürlich das war ein scherz was sie
einst gesagt habe also ich meine das
zitat war nicht aber es ist
es ist nicht richtig gewesen was er da
gemacht hat aber ihm den oscar
abzuerkennen
das ist so nicht das wäre so eine
cancelled culture reaktion von la roja
dass apple auch insgeheim dass diese
toxische männlichkeit gar nicht so
schlecht findet vielleicht nun man ja in
ihm auch so etwas
erinnert sich gern alleine wir sind
reden über hollywood
im letzten jahr so wenig zuschauer wie
nie zuvor also es musste auch was
passieren und vielleicht gab es ja auch
ein drehbuch aber das war ja ein scherz
das möchte ich eigentlich nur so am
rande erwähnt haben ich habe eigentlich
auch den ganzen tag gestern sehr viel
sympathie mit dieser toxischen
männlichkeit gehabt mit will smith bis
20 uhr 13 glaube ich in einem öffentlich
rechtlichen sender die tagesnachrichten
geschaut und neben mir saß mein
neunjähriger sohn so und dann musste ich
natürlich zu recht sagen nee das macht
man nicht und das war der moment wo ich
sagen stimmt wohl es mit was du gemacht
hast dann ist vielleicht also muss die
übertragung immer
noch besser hinkriegt oder toll wenn du
das auch für mich machen willst aber
sobald die kinder dabei setzen muss man
sagen nein geht überhaupt nicht und das
war der moment wo ich denke mein team
hat toxische milch gelangen also in dem
fall würde ich sagen es geht ein
bisschen meine sympathie roger köppel
obwohl ich für ihre einschätzung auch
verstehen staune hier ein bisschen über
diese unterdrückten
gewalt sehen sich die
wm für friedliche koexistenz jantscher
vernich für diese ohrfeige kommt unsere
quoten sind so gut dass wir das gar
nicht brauchen verleihung hat ein
wirkliches problem so und jetzt genau
auf diese auf diesen akt doch mal also
wenn wir noch mal darauf zurückkommen
also zum beispiel ich bin bei herr
maschmeyer ich finde es auch nicht
ausgabe zurückgeben und ich würde sogar
noch weiter gehen warum wird denn immer
jede menschliche regung ja fehler
gemacht er hat sich dann auch
entschuldigt und dann hat eine ohrfeige
verteilt also es ist nicht gut aber ich
habe jetzt gerade überlegt ob ich jetzt
meiner schwester die ist aber jetzt auch
schon über 20 sagen würde dass ich das
so schlimm finde ich finde es nicht so
schlimm eigentlich an der ritterlichkeit
bewiesen und was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen ist nicht nur gewalt ist gewalt
die körperlich ausgeführt wird worte
kann auch gewalt sei man aber jetzt
schauen sie wahrscheinlich jahre sagt
mein sohn vor der sehr guter schüler ist
aber nehmen wir uns mal an dem wir uns
mal vor oder überlegen wir uns seine
lehrerin würde ihm vor der klasse sagen
in den letzten arbeit hast du leider nur
eine vier oder fünf geschrieben und er
würde aufstehen und hingehen und die
eine kleine im vergleich angriff erklärt
die lehrerin feilte eltern auch hätte
jetzt die eltern beleidigt von ihrem
sohn ja aber auch dann wird und dann hat
er gesagt das darfst du nicht über mein
vater sagen und dann hätte er vielleicht
irgendwie reagieren und leider lehrerin
einen das macht ja einen schüler bei
einer lehrerin wie alt ist der junge
mann
da wird ja seine lehrerin kaum frauen
also körperliche gewalt geht gar nicht
ich habe ein bisschen verständnis für
die überreaktion weil es quasi zur
verteidigung der psychischen gewalt die
er empfunden hat die seiner frau gegen
derzeit gar nicht empfunden ich glaube
die frau war einfach nicht organisiert
er hat noch gelacht und ich du musst
dich aus führungskraft thema schwein sie
sind ein super erfolgreich der ist keine
führungskreisen ist eincremen künstler
was ist denn das für ein gewalt
relativismus in dieser runde ich bin ja
eine richtige etwas testosteronhaltigen
runde gelang 90 menschen ein nein nein
aber ich will wirklich du musst dich im
griff haben wenn zinedine zidane in
diesem berühmten fußballspiel den
italiener mit dem kopfstoß getroffen und
weil auch beleidigt worden ist dann
hatte auch sein eigenes seine
vorbildfunktion massiv ramponiert obwohl
man sich vorstellen kann was da auf den
fußball aber da bin ich der meinung nach
seine dann sie wären ist hätten beide
vom platz fliegen müssen wenn meine
mutter als [ __ ] bezeichnet wird und da
ist ja nun in einem weltmeisterschafts
endspiel auch adrenalin das ist ja werde
ich weltmeister oder nur der warten vom
platz fliegen können
auch verletzt natürlich bin ich ein sehr
gutes schlusswort zu deiner these roche
und wir bleiben eigentlich schon bei dem
thema vorbildfunktion denn carsten
maschmeyer hat auch ein thema
mitgebracht was sehr gut zu dem thema
passt
ich ärgere mich schon lange und immer
wieder und heute aktuell wie wir das
berufsbild kindern in schulen und in
büchern vermitteln ich war heute aktuell
in einer buchhandlung oder so zwei in
berlin und habe mir mal kinderbücher
angeguckt wenn ich mal groß werde
so dann alles klassisch alles
traditionell feuerwehrmann
polizist er kommt schon mal fast das
progressives sie doch gleich ganz anders
aus modedesignerin und da habe ich ein
buch entdeckt mein album vom ersten
schultag und das heißt der ernst des
lebens beginnt
und ich sehe das ganz anders es gibt
nämlich einen beruf der spaß macht bei
dem man am meisten lernt und das ist der
job das berufsbild von gründerinnen und
gründern und in all diesen büchern
nichts über erfinderin erfinder
innovation dabei brauchen wir die
innovation die erfindungen dass unsere
welt besser wird dass es digitaler wird
gesünder wird
nachhaltiger wird mehr die umwelt
beachtet wird und kinder sind die
fantasievollsten die ideenreichsten
menschen und die kreativsten die müssen
wir ganz früh fördern und darüber ist
nicht zu finden und das habe ich gemerkt
es gibt keine bücher darüber und
deswegen habe ich mit meinem co autor
axel teubert ein buch geschrieben wir
haben ein kindergerechtes
gründungs buch geschrieben ist also das
erste
unternehmerische buch für kinder und der
titel ist die start up ging und ich
möchte dass wir mehr gründen bekommen
mehr gründer und deswegen möchte ich
dass wir alle zusammen unsere kinder
frühzeitig motivieren und für diesen
faszinierenden beruf gewinnen
ich habe ja noch keine kinder kann mich
immer noch gut auf an meine kindheit
erinnern und zum beispiel wir durften
oder sollten nicht mit baby born spielen
weil mein vater und auch meine mutter
nicht das gefühl hat dass es sinnvoll
ist dass ich schon mit vier jahren die
mutter mine zu hause und auch ich würde
auch heute sagen das war gar nicht so
schlecht ich finde aber dass mit den
büchern m ganz spannend und auf einem
auch sehr wichtig es gibt ja auch bücher
die sie nur für jungs geschrieben und
nur für mädchen geschrieben das ist dort
auch immer noch sehr auseinander nur die
frage die ich mir stelle ist mit dem
buch wenn das kind das dann liest wie
kann man denn dann weiter machen und die
fähigkeiten auch weiter ausbauen ich
finde ist vor allem wichtig dass die
jungen menschen die kinder und
jugendliche entdecken neben den
klassischen berufen die ja in der regel
einer angestellten welt darstellen eine
arbeitnehmer rolle dass es eben diese
faszination der selbstständigkeit des
unternehmertums des gründen ob das ein
kleiner handwerksbetrieb ist ob das der
friseursalon dass es eben diese
berufswelt aufgibt und das wollte ich
ändern das kommt in kinderbüchern bisher
nicht vor
teile die diagnose ich teile ihre
diagnose und ich glaube es hängt damit
zusammen dass
unternehmer bei uns in der
öffentlichkeit generell ein viel
schlechteres image haben als schade
verdienen man das immer deutlicher dass
er ja
es sind leute die viel zu viel verdienen
nachdem graf kernig sind schmarotzer
sind und so weiter also wer mal
beobachtet hat wie viel diese leute so
arbeiten der
korrigiert die diese auffassung aber das
ist das ist der widerschein des
unternehmertums wie einem in der
öffentlichkeit oft begegnet dass das
aber nicht der realität entspricht also
dass das nicht dem entspricht was die
leute auf der straße viele von ihnen
jedenfalls denken zeigt der erfolg
dieser fernseh show in der sie setzen
können
die ja unheimlich
eingeschlagen hat und die von nichts
anderem handelt als von leuten eine gute
idee haben und eine leidenschaft für
diese idee haben und dann im bereich
werden leider einige von ihnen natürlich
nicht alle aber einige von ihnen
schaffen dass das ist daneben und dieser
dieser gedanke
ich erfinde etwas oder ich stelle etwas
auf die beine was die leute brauchen was
im idealfall ihr leben besser macht oder
irgendetwas in einer irgend ein
bedürfnis erfüllt
etwas wunderbares eigentlich das wird
bei uns nicht genug gewürdigt
man nimmt den rücken übel dass sie dafür
dann im extremfall viel geld bekommen
während man leuten die sagen wir mal
eine politische karriere machen die
verdienen natürlich nicht so viel wie
ein erfolgreicher unternehmer aber man
nimmt ihnen das auch nicht so übel dass
sie mehr verdienen als der durchschnitt
sie haben langen arbeitstag ja diesen
langen arbeitstag hat ein unternehmer
aber auch und er muss natürlich auch um
erfolg zu haben auf dieses und jenes
verzichten das ist dann auch ein preis
den man dem ansinnen der startup welt
kenne ich in unserem portfolio wir sind
130 start-ups beteiligt kein
gründungsteam wo die gesagt haben wir
haben gegründet um reich zu werden die
wollen ein problem lösen die wollen
sparsam die wollen ein bisschen die welt
verändern und
915 startups es kann man rechnet wie
früh beginnt das scheitern ja dh die
haben alles geld was wir am anfang
selbst reingesteckt haben von der oma
geliehen und was war die vorzeitiges
erbe sie haben drei lebensjahre
verschenkt das ist ja auch eine chance
risiko profil und ich möchte dass wir
eben mit kindern auch über risiken rät
über rückschläge selbst bayern münchen
gewinnt nicht jedes spiel wir müssen
eben niederlagen dass man das wieder
aufstehen werden und darüber handelt
dieses buch ich habe ja einen sicheren
job aufgegeben hier im springer-verlag
ich war chefredakteur der welt da bin
ich in die schweiz zurück gegangen habe
ich mit millionen verschuldet meine
firma zu übernehmen und ich bin aber
leider etwas später ins unternehmerische
eingestiegen wie sie
und ich teile ihre analyse und hätten
sie es gelesen
getraut hatte nicht dieses titanische
selbstvertrauen das sie auszeichnet aber
sagen sie haben recht der unternehmen
das unternehmerische denken das ist
etwas elementares in unserer kultur ich
mein deutschland die schweiz österreich
wie sie durch diese unternehmer kmu
kleine und mittlere unternehmen das sind
auch startups sind wir groß geworden und
ich möchte das noch unterstreichen was
der hörer steige sagte tiere haben die
medien eine riesige verantwortung weil
die medien sind für mich viel zu politik
hören die die die rennen da den schleier
den politikern in trier und die
unternehmer die werden immer noch
kritisch fertig gemacht auch mit diesen
eid kultur und man müsste viel mehr
druck auf die politik machen dass die
politik eine unternehmerfreundliche
politik macht das heißt die belastungen
zurücknimmt dass man die unternehmen die
bürger entlastet damit der risiko geist
belohnt wird wobei nichts gegen den
beruf des polizisten aus ich wäre froh
wenn wir brauchen wir polizisten sind
auch gut das ist auch ein toller job du
kannst ja auch zuerst polizist werden
und demnach unternehmen ich wollte
gleich gestellt wo sie bleiben wir ganz
kurz dann würde ich gerne hand fragen
bleiben wir ganz kurz bei dem punkt wie
der unternehmer in den medien
dargestellt wird und ein punkt ist ja
der dass viele journalisten eher links
sind da gibt es ja auch studien zur
letzten befragung ist schon ein paar
jahre her aber da hat man ganz klar
gesehen der linksruck den gibt es schon
im journalismus wie würdest du es
einschätzen warum der unternehmer weil
das mit dem tatort stimmt wirklich
verletzt auch wieder sehr erschrocken
über eine folge tatort als wieder der
unternehmer der raffgierige war und der
mörder war ja ich glaube da sind wir uns
dieser runde hier ziemlich einig das ist
in der tat etwas und roger köppel hat es
ja gerade noch mal gesagt das geht
eigentlich vom kopf runter bis er so von
von der von der politik vor
bundeskanzlers oder der bundeskanzlerin
runter dann bis in die schulen also wir
fangen beim steuersystem an wenn wir uns
die debatte von letzter woche noch
einmal vor augen führen als es darum
ging ja wie entlasten wir eigentlich und
wie entlasten wir da war am ende immer
die frage jede suv fahrer und der
porsche-fahrer die dürften also nicht
entlastet werden und jetzt können wir
davon ausgehen vielleicht ist der
porsche fahrer eher jemand der ein
bisschen mehr verdient hat oder auch der
suv fahrer aus welchen gründen auch
immer möglicherweise sind ja auch
unternehmer darunter und automatisch
schwimmt ja dann hier schon mit in genau
diesen aussagen erstmalig das für teil
rassistisch weil es gegen eine gewisse
gruppe geht und diskriminierung sowie
wird nur spalten genau hier wird nicht
zusammengeführt hier wird gespalten also
von respekt kann man da gar nicht reden
auch wenn die partei des bundeskanzlers
immer von respekt im wahlkampf
gesprochen hat also hier wurde gespielt
und ganz klar
hin gespalten zu menschen die
möglicherweise ein bisschen mehr
verdienen also die sind per se schon mal
wäre und mir sagen sie vielen gründern
und das ist total ehren wird geht es gar
nicht ums geldverdienen klar auch in den
hinterkopf geklappt und die haben geld
verdienen warum hat aber sogar das ist
ja schon wichtig zu wissen wie ihr seht
ihr ein deutschland interessanterweise
dass es ganz ganz viele junge leute auch
geht die sich zum beispiel nichts
sehnlicher wünschen als beim staat
angestellt zu sein da verdient man in
deutschland zum teil extrem muss man
sagen und man hat nach sicheren job dann
kein riefen von c und man muss freilich
beleidigen lassen dass man wenn man mit
dem porsche beispielsweise vorgefahren
kommt und den suv gleich die ganzen
finger im gesicht hat du bist aber
offenbar jemand der reichen du bist
eigentlich b du hast eigentlich
irgendwie gemauschelt und irgendwas
falsch gemacht und um auf diese frage
zurückzukommen wir haben ein
gravierendes problem in deutschland ein
gravierendes problem denn am ende wissen
wir auch dass es die unternehmer sind
die die jobs schaffen ja höhere risiko
ich habe das risiko und verantwortung
für andere menschen zu übernehmen das
ist endlich schaffen die arbeitsplätze
ich war am freitag an der polnischen
grenze habe das hotel wichtig und
besucht wo das wir angemietet haben um
ukrainische
flüchtlingsfamilien meist mütter mit
kindern jüngst ist vier wochen die
älteste frau aus 80 jahre besucht haben
und neben der großen dankbarkeit was
arbeiterwohlfahrt rote kreuz die stadt
die mitarbeiterin alle leisten über 1
schütteln den kopf die digitalisierung
die sind in der ukraine gewohnt dass sie
die digitale identität
haben klack klack ist der pass
verlängert jetzt stehen die da und bis
werden listen ausgefüllt abgeheftet
kopiert die wollen die sprache lernen
sie wollen arbeiten aber das erste
dauert mindestens drei wochen bis sie
irgendwie sprachunterricht bekommen und
damit jetzt ich für dieses buch die
werbung nicht falsch verstehen haben
mein co autor und ich entschieden alle
autoren erlöse die wir pro buch bekommen
werden wir haben die uno für die ukraine
flüchtlingshilfe spenden das also ich
will etwas verändern und wollte mich
hier nicht bereichern ich hoffe dass wir
vielleicht in ein paar jahren in höhle
der löwen mal ein gründungsteam haben
die gesagt haben weil wir es buch
gelesen haben dass doch ein schöner ab
und damit gehen wir einen ganz kurzen
unterbrechungen sind gleich wieder
zurück
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück was den r8
meine liebe damen und herren und wir
machen direkt weiter mit bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer und seinem thema des
tages
bei mir geht es heute um die öko lügen
der grünen wir sind in schwerer see in
schwerem fahrwasser die grünen in der
regierung und sie müssen eigentlich in
den letzten wochen immer wieder einsehen
dass wir hier in dem doch völlig falsch
gelegen haben bestes beispiel heute die
umweltministerin steffi lemke hat ihren
aktionsplan natürlich in klimaschutz
vorgestellt und da waren mehrere punkte
bemerkenswert unter anderem fordert frau
lemke das alte bäume nicht mehr
abgeholzt werden sollen ganz speziell
alte buchen ja warum nicht weil sie
besonders gute co2 speicher sind jetzt
erinnern wir uns aber dass ausgerechnet
die grünen auch befürworten das im
hessischen reinhardswald dem brüder
grimm war dem märchenwald deutschlands
viele viele alte bäume dort stehen
wollen wir die 100 95 jahre alt sind
abgeholzt werden sollen warum weiter
windräder hin sollen nach prima passt ja
super da hat rolle heute was weiteres
gesagt sie hat gesagt dass sie dafür
kämpfen will mit dem aktionsplan dass es
in deutschland intakte sehen intakte
mehren natürlich intakte küsten aber
auch intakte blöden geben soll na prima
denn jeder aber warum sollen dann dieses
land eigentlich zubetoniert werden mit
windkraftanlagen wir wissen ja wenn so
ein windrad kraft wenn windrad
aufgestellt wird dann wird der ganze
boden drumherum ganz ganz fest mit einem
sockel betoniert da kann kein regenbogen
mehr durch da ist auch fließt auch kein
wasser ab das ist richtig dicht dann das
ganze thema reinhardswald überhaupt ein
irres projekt was da geplant wird wir
erinnern uns an den humvee dort wurde
diese haben wie belagert von grünen von
öko aktivisten über wochen über monate
weil der hambüchen sollte ein wald um
dort kohletagebau betreiben zu können
beziehungsweise kohle abzubauen jetzt da
wir das gleiche problem im reinhard
zweiter sollen auch bäume gefällt werden
aber für windräder und plötzlich gibt es
so gut wie gar keinen protest und ich
erinnere mich auch noch an die zeit vor
der korona krise als wir in deutschland
darüber diskutiert haben dass wir
aufforsten wollen überall so
aufgeforstet werden aber wir sehen auch
wieder im reinhardswald soll abgeholzt
werden also das passt alles nicht
zusammen die öko lügen der grünen der
klimaaktivisten sind etwas was wir jetzt
wirklich entlassen
na ja also ich weiß nicht ob das lügen
sind es ist vielleicht mangel der
realismus und man kann den grünen finde
ich nicht vorwerfen dass sie nicht jetzt
in dieser bundesregierung dazu lernen
beim wirtschaftsminister harbeck ist mir
das besonders deutlich geworden dass er
ganz offensichtlich zu
kompromissen bereit ist die vor einem
jahr bei einem grünen minister noch
undenkbar gewesen berichten gewähren die
reise nach katar ist ein beispiel dafür
ja wenn das jemand von der fdp gemacht
hätte so vor zwei jahren hätten sie in
der luft zerrissen aber man sie lernen
eben dazu und das kann man niemandem
vorwerfen finde ich aber natürlich
stimme ich ihnen vielen punkten zu ich
wohne teilweise in der uckermark das ist
eine wunderschöne landschaft
und viel mehr als wunderschöne
landschaft gibt es da auch nicht der
einzige wirtschaftszweig der ist schon
gewisse erfolgsaussichten zu haben
scheint ist der tourismus gewesen da hat
er angefangen sich zu entwickeln wenn
man das zupflastern mit windrädern ist
das natürlich abgewürgt und wenn sie in
die dörfer gehen es gibt auch
interessante romane über solche
konflikte wenn sie die dörfer geben dann
stellen sie fest dass zwischen denen die
ihr land verkaufen dann für viel geld
damit der windräder gebaut werden können
und den anderen passiert in den krach
haben und
ganz ganz gewaltige konflikte bestehen
also der plan
unser energieproblem zu lösen indem man
das ganze land mit windrädern zu
pflastern scheint mir eher einer der
unrealistischen sorte zu sein dann muss
ich das noch vorstellen
die größe des saarlandes dieses das ist
so ein ganz ordentlicher fleck auf der
deutschen landkarte
seid also wirklich komplett mit
windrädern bitte das ist der plan und
mir hat noch niemand erklären können wo
diese windräder eigentlich hin sollen
weil alle angst davor haben das zu
erklären weil wenn sie erklären wo sie
hin sollen dann gibt es einen aufstand
in sämtlichen gegenden also wir haben
aber berechnen lassen will ich das ganz
gut laufen darf vom deutschen institut
für wirtschaftsforschung von frau
professor claudia kemfert ja bekannt und
jetzt sicherlich keine anhängerin der
fdp und der union
und jetzt berechnet wenn man den plan
von robert habeck bis 20.30 quasi aus
der kohle und aus der kernenergie
aussteigen möchte und 80 prozent
erneuerbare energien hinbekommen möchte
umsetzen möchte dann müsste man
wahrscheinlich zwei bis drei vielleicht
sogar vier windräder jeden tag aufstehen
also wir reden über windräder alle acht
stunden ein neues das tempo das müssen
sie erstmal hinbekommen und da sind wir
genau bei den punkt jeder ernannten der
plan ist ein krieg aber es ist schön die
grünen waren in der opposition haben ihr
fokus ziel immer umgesetzt und jetzt
sind sie in der realität angelangt dass
auch die wirtschaft funktionieren muss
denn wenn wir ein bisschen grüner werden
aber auf einmal die riesen
arbeitslosigkeit haben oder ähnliche
zwinge er hat natürlich wurde die ganzen
grünen haben jetzt eine situation wir
wollen ja möglichst schnell am besten
sofort von den fossilen brennstoffen aus
russland weg kein gas kein öl mehr und
dann brauchen wir natürlich wind dreht
aber es ist ja nur eine sache wir können
erdwärme wir können
solardächer wir können wasserstoff
machen was ich nicht verstehe wirklich
dass wald abgeholzt werden muss dann
müsste ja in jedem bundesland gleich
viel wald gleich viel windräder dieser
quatsch es gibt im norden er
ja bald freie gebiete wo es sehr viel
wind gibt wären dann gibt es welche wo
nicht so viel wind ist das muss ja nicht
gleich aufgeteilt sein also bäume zu
killen die grüne lunge um windenergie zu
haben das halte ich auch für völlig
pizza ja das wird auch wie der
verteilungskämpfe geben klassische
verteilungskämpfe die bayern haben sich
ja bisher sehr zurückgehalten mit den
windrädern ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass die anderen bundesländer in ihnen
das auf die dauer durchgehen lassen und
dann möchte ich mal sehen wer den herrn
soll dann zement und eben klar gemacht
dass der windräder in oberammergau
entstehen sollen ich bin sehr beruhigt
dass
diese übergriff der grünen auf das
heiligtum des deutschen war das jetzt
ihre skripte skepsis und kritik auslösen
werde er war schmerzlich gesagt ich
meine die stärke der grünen ist sie
nicht bis jetzt unbedingt der realismus
gewesen sondern man hat sich da auch in
diese wolken schlösser da hinein
geträumt und das gute ist im grunde dass
das jetzt einfach ans licht kommt weil
man könnte argumentieren dass die ganze
kernenergie ausstiegspolitik unter
ökologischen gesichtspunkten
hochgradig fragwürdige ist ja weil wir
in deutschland so viel tsunamis und
erdbeben genau das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig habe ich natürlich ausgeblendete
verharmlost sie haben völlig recht
das nicht machen wein und und das ist
genau das problem diese grünen politik
dass man die gute absicht die gesinnung
nach oben stellt aber die praktischen
auswirkungen die verantwortung dafür die
politik zurück gestellt und das ist dann
nicht so wichtig ich habe ja angefangen
als grüner ich bin ein original grüner
durch das waldsterben habe ich einen
kleinen button getragenen baum ab nein
danke warm-up nein danke das war
sozusagen das evangelium der grünen aber
heute sind sie bereit auf dem autor
dieser windräder und sonnenkollektoren
auch das den wunderbaren deutschen wald
abzuholzen da müsst ihr euch wären also
damit ist sie dagegen deutlich dass das
ist offenbar doch die grünen werden in
der realität angekommen ich sehe das
noch nicht so ganz denn und diese stadt
die realität konfrontiert die und das
waren sie vorher nie genau da angekommen
das ist richtig das ist der erste
schritt um dann vielleicht auch mal an
zu kommen aber angenehm sind sie meiner
meinung nach noch nicht überhaupt nicht
und wir reden immer oder auch nicht wie
er aber in der bundesregierung wird
darüber geredet warum man das ziel 2030
80 prozent erneuerbare energien
erreichen muss und dass man es deswegen
auch erreichen wird das ziel bisher das
finde ich gut wenn das alles klappt ist
das ja toll aber wir haben bis dahin ja
nur ein drehbuch und wir haben keine
garantie dass es klappt und wir reden
hier immer noch über die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt und wir wissen
auch dass es die unternehmen
beispielsweise gibt die selbst sagen und
sind die energiekosten nicht als nicht
chemieunternehmen oder autobauer aber
sogar ein unternehmen die sagen und sind
die energiekosten hier in deutschland
eigentlich schon zu hoch das ist doch
ein alarmsignal wenn wir über die frage
reden und verstehen geeinigt eine
sichere und idealerweise noch
unabhängige und dann auf fleisch sogar
noch einigermaßen kostengünstige werden
versorgungen die grünen auf dem schirm
behalten weil jetzt möchten wir gerne
peróns heimat zu unterscheiden wir haben
ihn die befehle 80er versprochen dass
wir sind weiterhin ihr immer wieder
darüber informieren werden wie es in der
ukraine ist und paul ist da ja ich sehe
ich schon hinter mir
bevor du jetzt deine these macht
vielleicht erstmal wie ist die aktuelle
lage in kiew du bist ja einer der
letzten journalisten vor ort
janina ich bin tatsächlich gerade eben
wieder gekommen von einem interview mit
vitali klitschko dem bürgermeister und
alle reden über den angeblichen abzug
hier aus kiew und dass die russischen
truppen doch schon so gut wie weg sein
und jetzt der große frieden kommt ich
übertreibe wie du hörst aber vitali
klitschko der kam gerade von der front
oder sagte da wird weiterhin heftig
gekämpft und bravery zum beispiel einem
vorort von kiew und er sagt er glaubt
der russischen armee gar nichts denn sie
wurden hier nur belogen 1 1994 als man
die atomwaffen abgegeben hat gegen eine
sicherheitsgarantie die da nichts wert
war und dann der krieg der nicht kommen
sollte und jetzt diese ankündigung dass
man angeblich einen teilabzug mache
viele menschen in der ukraine
eingeschlossen viele politiker glauben
dass das ganze ein taktischer rückzug
ist weil man hier nicht weitergekommen
ist in der hauptstadt um sich jetzt zu
rekrutieren im donbass den dornbusch
ganz zu erobern und da dies erneut
zu versuchen richtung hilft zu kommen
und du hast uns heute auch eine these
mitgebracht paul die dich ja sehr bewegt
so ist es nina ich glaube nach all dem
was wir diesen tagen erlebt haben in
diesen wochen erlebt haben in diesen
jahren erlebt haben was deutsche
politiker im umgang mit russland im
umgang mit wladimir putin im umgang mit
dem kreml angeht brauchen wir dringend
einen untersuchungsausschuss nach dem
krieg und zwar muss untersucht werden
welche motive wirklich dahinter steckten
was frank walter steinmeier der
kanzleramtsminister außenminister und
jetzige bundespräsident dort mit
wladimir putin und la france besprochen
hat wie eng der bund war was mit gerhard
schröder passiert ist aber auch was
angela merkel wirklich angetrieben hat
so lange so deutlich hinter wladimir
putin zu stehen ich bin dafür dass
aktuelle und ehemalige politiker in
diesem zusammenhang durchleuchtet werden
sollten denn wir brauchen in deutschland
eine neue aufklärung eine aufklärung
über das was wir lange zeit in richtung
russland getan haben nur so können wir
überhaupt wieder vertrauen
zurückgewinnen auch in der
internationalen gemeinschaft wenn man
sich in diesen tagen mit amerikanern
austauscht auch mit briten die fragen
immer nur was war da los bei euren
politikern loos jan
die frage die ich mir gerade stelle kann
man denn nicht auch sagen dass so
absprachen unter der hand auch ein
beitrag zur demokratie sein können
das kann natürlich ein beitrag zur
demokratie sein aber ich finde den
vorschlag den paul gemacht hat
mindestens diskussionswürdig wenn ich
sogar auch am ende ein den man ins
parlament tragen muss um genau darüber
auch zu sprechen ich befürchte
allerdings auch lieber paul dass die
meisten politiker oder wenn es um diese
untersuchungsausschuss geht die meisten
parteien er damit verdeckten karten
spielen werden bis auf fdp und grüne die
ja zuletzt eine doch deutliche distanz
zum kreml hatten sind eigentlich alle
anderen parteien die bundestag vertreten
sind ja in eine art und weise dann mit
dem kreml verbandelt will ich nicht
sagen aber pflegten doch mehr oder
weniger starke beziehungen in den kreml
also angefangen natürlich von der
linkspartei über die spd über die union
bis hin zur afg von daher glaube ich
dass dieser ausschuss wichtig wäre der
erkenntnisgewinn am ende wahrscheinlich
nicht so großes einfach weil es zu viele
interessen gibt zuviel organisierten
widerstand also unser image ist da
teilweise dadurch nicht gut ich war vor
zehn tagen noch in amerika und ich hatte
einen ober fahrer ein ukrainischer sagte
ja vom germany und so ja er war sehr
nett zu russland viel zu nett also dass
das registrieren die auch das kann
sinnvoll sein rückwärts etwas zu
untersuchen ich glaube vorwärts jetzt
die sanktionen noch zu verschärfen
ist noch wichtiger wenn sie gehen herr
maschmeyer beim verschärfen ich würde so
weit gehen dass wir kein russisches gas
und öl
neben aus russland wir sind ja dann
nicht sofort dass wir hier eine eiszeit
haben und nichts mehr geht wir können
aus norwegen aus großbritannien aus usa
öl und gas bekommen wahrscheinlich wird
es teurer wir können noch mehr erdwärme
machen wir können auch die
atomkraftwerke die wenigen die wir noch
haben noch ein bisschen länger laufen
lassen und vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen länger kohle wir kriegen
atomstrom aus nachbarländern frankreich
schaltet nichts ab die bauern sogar drei
neue atomkraftwerke
wir sollten das probieren erst wenn der
druck so hochkommt und vielleicht das
geld wenn die berechnungen stimmen für
die kriegsmaschine gar nicht mehr da ist
dann ist vielleicht noch er ist möglich
dass der schreckliche krieg diese
sauerei von krieg aufhört roche
untersuchungsausschuss was hältst du von
paredes these theorie oder herr
martenstein beide wie es ihrer meinung
nach aus ich bin ein grundsätzlich muss
die priorität eins muss es sein diesen
krieg zu beenden weil mit jedem tag wo
das länger geht ist dann wird das elend
monumental durch ein zeichen mit ich hab
dich einfach sei nicht irgendwie ohne
das zu wissen ich habe anfang des jahres
ein leitartikel geschrieben wie gesagt
das motto ist eigentlich friedliche
koexistenz
und jetzt plötzlich auf zwei jahren
corona landen wir in diesem
fürchterlichen krieg den eben erst hat
und unsicher und fand jetzt in haft das
muss man stoppen ich würde aber raten
von solchen
untersuchungskommissionen das wird dann
auch für politische schaukämpfe für
abrechnungen benutzt das sind dann die
gerichtshöfe der moral jede der armut in
die hand geschüttelt hat wird dann je
nach politischer ausrichtung da
angeprangert das kann auch ein paar auch
noch unangenehm die reihe der
journalisten wahrscheinlich wollen weißt
du eigentlich
dort sagt das könnte auch unangenehm
werden für einige könnte auch unangenehm
werden für einige journalisten wenn man
noch alte titel und alte leitartikel
raus und konnte dann jeder sehen ich bin
einfach gegen diese
inquisitorischen verfahren und ich meine
deutschland hatte eine geschichte von
800 jahren beziehungen mit russland ich
meine das ist ja nicht einfach was jetzt
aus dem jetzigen zustand der auch zu
beurteilen und man muss den leuten bei
der rechtsstaat muss geld wenn einer ein
gesetz verlängert weil etwas eingestellt
sagte gesagt hat dann muss man ihn jetzt
vor gericht wehren wenn einmal daran
gedacht trotzdem das muss ich dann schon
mal sagen wir reden hier über den
größten kriegsverbrecher im 21
jahrhundert und es gab in diesem
bundestag viele viele politiker die mit
herrn putin so umgegangen sind als wäre
das buddy wie ihk in paris und ich
glaube dass es da schon extreme
unterschiede gibt und es deswegen auch
das recht ist auch der bundesbürger zu
wissen wer hat eigentlich wie mit diesem
kriegsverbrecher gekungelt wer hat
eigentlich wie die lsk oder ist
zumindest drauf reingefallen oder hat
man doch
fielen dann also dass er einen
kriegsverbrecher dieser dimension werden
würde war ja vor einigen jahren nicht
abzusehen auch beste russland kenner
haben sich ja überrascht gezeigt darüber
dass putin tatsächlich da einmarschiert
ist also ich bin kein russland könnte
ich lese nur das was sie schreiben und
offensichtlich also man kann von den
menschen nicht verlangen dass sie
hellseher sind würde ich da sagen
ich wünsche mir sehr dass wir also
deutschland mehr für die ukraine tun
denn klar der krieg soll ende möglichst
bald aber ich wünsche mir nicht dass er
damit endet dass putin seine ziele
erreicht nämlich die ukraine zu einer
art kolonie zu machen und irgendeiner
marionette an die spitze zu setzen zu
einem weißrussland nur einen total
kaputten und zerbombten und weißrussland
aus dem dann alle menschen geflohen sind
ja das sollte nicht passieren weil das
eine riesige ermutigung wäre weltweit
für leute für diktatoren die appetit auf
in china hunger auf teure ja also das
sollte nicht passieren und deswegen und
da sind wir wieder bei der geheimen
seite der politik ich hätte überhaupt
nichts dagegen würden wir die ukraine
mit mit waffen unterstützen und zwar in
größerem umfang als das bisher bekannt
ist denn ich gestehe ich hoffe dass die
ukraine diesen konflikt gewinnt das ist
bei kleinen schluss wollten wir sind am
ende der sendung angekommen ich bedanke
mich sehr bei meinen gästen und
natürlich auch bei paul ronzheimer der
uns läuft unsere ukraine zugeschaltet
war und jetzt schönen abend noch ein wie
bis morgen 20.15 tschüss